let's try our next caller from the 484
caller from 484 what's your name where
you go from yes hello David
yes sir I'd come down and come pee a
hole in the wall
what's on your mind and let's turn them
up just I can bare large area well
that's strange that speakerphones uh but
um I'm just curious um about the whole
gun issue which is what what why exactly
is it that America is so unique among
its gun culture and like do you think
we've gone past the point of no return
when it comes to guns like have we are
we just like going like we just have too
many that it would be almost impossible
to take all the guns away at least
democratically wise you know what I'm
saying yeah I mean I first of all I
don't know of anyone trying to take all
the guns away so I think it's not
particularly relevant to even think
about could we take all the guns away I
think the real question is are can we
past 100% background checks that don't
allow any sales or transfers of guns can
be past mandatory gun insurance can we
restrict the ability of people to get
high-capacity magazines and devices that
clearly serve no purpose other than just
doing massive destruction in a car to a
I mean a cartoonish almost makes it
sound like it's not serious but it's
it's so serious that it is almost
cartoonish the damage that some of these
firearms can do but I think that there
is something about American culture
including the idea of you know the
original colonies and then manifest
destiny of spreading out to the west and
the idea of the homestead and protecting
your homestead with firearms I think
you're right that there is definitely
something cultural that goes above and
beyond just the logic of the number of
guns that that are out there and sort of
what makes sense compared to other
countries and you know what Jared I
don't know of any way to change that
yeah it's it's definitely a problem with
our gun culture it really is but I just
always think back to Australia that you
know they also had a gun culture as well
yeah and you know eventually they got
rid of theirs as well but uh hey thank
you for the call and just also just to
let you know that there's a guy named
Jimmy door I don't know if you can have
among your program but I would recommend
and definitely as a guest all right all
the kids in the door that's do re right
yeah do re got it okay I'll check into
that
alright thanks Jared always great to
hear from Jared from Downingtown
Pennsylvania